hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
august 8th
2022
what's going on
how are ya
jesus christ august 8th already
where is the summer going jesus christ
every year we say it we say we need to
enjoy it
we say we need to enjoy it and it by the
time you get the
pool inflated it's time to take it down
it's crazy
um well fortunately there's global
warming so the summer continues into
like the first week of october all right
so you got time you still got time to
get your
uh revenge body
i love that whole idea of revenge body
you broke up with me i'm gonna get my
vengeance
by getting in shape well maybe if you
weren't a dumpy [ __ ] you wouldn't got
broken up with you ever think of that
you let yourself go
you took your foot off the gas
um
also they were nice enough to realize
they didn't love you and they let you go
so now you can find true love someone
who will accept you for who you are
a person who stays in shape to get
somebody and then lets themselves go no
i'm kidding
anyway uh
i don't even know where to begin with
this [ __ ] week i had um
this whole [ __ ] world man
is so much nicer than it's being
presented on social media to the point
people are like literally losing their
[ __ ] minds i was driving over a buddy
of mine's house
you're writing something right and i'm
driving down the street and a guy
outside his house
he had a sign that said warning
my sense of humor might offend your
liberal sensibilities or something like
that
he had that outside his house
first of all
i just don't like the whole footloose
vibe of that guy
you know
like he's [ __ ] you know moving to the
small town and we're not allowed to
dance and he's gonna show us what the
real world is like
it's first of all no one's going in your
house
warning man the way i joke around you're
not going to be able to handle it man
because you're too sensitive man you
can't handle the real world
the way i can man
you know i was just talking to somebody
you know what's funny is how like
[ __ ] dumbass liberals
like don't even know what's going on in
the [ __ ] world because they they they
call like 48 of the 50 states like
flyover states because they're too good
for it right
and then the [ __ ] morons living in
the red states don't know [ __ ] about the
bluest and it i don't know
it's a weird thing when you go to both
and you're kind of like yeah everybody's
just kind of cool man like i don't know
everybody's just sort of uh
going out doing their thing getting a
sandwich
it's not a whole bunch of [ __ ] going on
here
um
i was just talking to somebody you know
about that that stereotype of hollywood
that there's all these guys up in the
hills
you know
[ __ ]
pedophiles banging underage chicks and
all this [ __ ] right
and uh the red states always say that
and then you look at the red states and
their age of consent on average is 16
years old so it's like well what the
[ __ ] are you guys doing out there
i think it's safe to assume that if you
moved out to california where the age of
consent is 18 a lot of you guys would be
in the same [ __ ] trouble
uh
oh
billy's going hypocrisy on this one
i'm not i'm not i'm just [ __ ] around
that sign just [ __ ]
that sign is is the number one thing
that is just cringe towards the when you
watch uh
either a movie or you uh some [ __ ]
rock star or a comedian anything
that is there anything worse than the
[ __ ] person that thinks they're
dangerous
and they're not and they do like that
preemptive because you know i know you
know me
you don't know what's gonna come out of
my mouth
i like when women are just like you know
you know guys can't handle me most
people can't [ __ ] just completely
wrapped up into like the universe of
them
like how [ __ ] up like what like that
guy i swear to god
who has that sign he comes home and
turns on the 24-hour news network that
agrees with him and just fills his head
with that [ __ ] and then he goes online
and and types in capital letters
like why would you waste your [ __ ]
i don't know but then on the other side
he's living out here in california he's
conservative
he's probably sick of his neighbors i'm
trying to go empathy in my older age you
know
not like there isn't a bunch of wild
stupid [ __ ] out here i really don't have
a dog in the fight to be honest with you
at this point
um
but anyway oh my god
you're not gonna [ __ ] believe what
happened to me i went to uh spending
time with my kids and i went to one of
these little
playland things for kids
and they had this structure where once
your kids went in it like you couldn't
really go in there
and be with the kids see it's kind of
this you know it's unsettling because
they go around the corner you can't see
them there's a whole bunch of people
there there's a whole bunch of adults
and it's like i think everybody here is
a parent i don't know what's going on it
just it had that [ __ ] uh
flying the ointment vibe so i already
didn't like it
and i'm in there my son's in there and
there was
this bigger kid was trying to give him a
plastic ball my son's you know only two
he doesn't know what's going on the kid
got frustrated took the [ __ ] ball and
smashed it over my son's head like twice
so
i'm on the mesh thing going hey hey hey
you know
stop doing that knock it off so my son's
freaked out he like runs away and the
big kid i don't know if he felt bad he
[ __ ] runs over to him and like my
son's freaking out like get the [ __ ]
away from me and i can't get in there to
break it up so all i can use is my voice
so that's what i'm using and then the
dad came over right and he's on the
other side of the structure
he gets the kid to get away and then he
looks at me and he goes like
yeah we good bro
are we good
that's what he says to me and like
listen
i'm no tough guy but like something
about when somebody tries to bully me i
forget that i you know haven't had a
fight in three decades
so i take a step towards the mesh and i
go
what
and i forget what else he said so next
thing you know this [ __ ]
idiot
is walking through the structure like
hunched over like the hunchback of notre
dame coming over to my side and i go
here we go
i'm like is he coming in here to keep a
closer eye on his kid or what's gonna
happen so i'm standing at the bottom of
this [ __ ] area i'm standing ankle
deep in colorful balls and this [ __ ]
dad comes in he doesn't look at me he's
got his back to me and he starts like
bumping into me
right
with his back to me you know i don't
know a lot about mma and martial arts
and defense but i don't think that's a
good way to start a physical
confrontation let me turn my back on you
start bumping into you
so i address it and then he turns around
and he looks at me goes he goes what do
you like what are you like a buck 80.
i thought he was going to ask me how
much i bench
so i just smile and i just look at him
right i'm like all right
this guy out weighs me like 60 pounds so
he's gonna lunge at me i'm gonna jump
back and take the back of his head push
him down the plastic balls and i'm gonna
get out of here
that was my only move
um
and it just keeps going and then he
starts he turns his back again right
because i just sort of laughed when he
said it
i said i forget what the [ __ ] i said i
just laughed at him because i knew
i kind of feel like if someone's gonna
hit you they just go in and do it they
don't come in and turn their back to you
and it's just like all right this guy is
doing he's
he's going uh machismo here he's trying
to he's trying to urinate all over this
space so if i was more mature i would
have given up the space but i'm a
[ __ ] bald orange [ __ ] so i don't
and i stand there and then he starts
talking [ __ ] about me not looking at me
so i go is that is that directed at me
and he's like no i'm just talking to
myself
it's a free country
you biden voters haven't taken that away
yet i go jesus i go you're one of those
24-hour news watching guys
and then he tried to flip it around and
be like oh it's because i'm brown right
i guess he was mexican i don't know i
don't know what he was he was fat that's
what i knew
and uh
and whatever we're just going back and
forth and i'm really [ __ ]
i don't know it's like i'm enjoying it
but i'm not it's you know because my
kids are there and [ __ ] so we're just
john back and forth they're the ones
that's gonna back down and then this
asian dude came in this is a very
progressive story we got like almost
every race is involved here
um the asian version of i was gonna say
nice guy eddie nice guy eddie was not a
nice guy but that i would've uh we're
gonna call him nice guy yeti he comes
and he goes hey come on guys not in
front of the kids not in front of the
kids then he goes to give me a fist bump
and i i was more mad at him than the
other guy
like what the [ __ ] are you trying to
settle me down for i didn't [ __ ] do
anything this this guy's [ __ ] lunatic
kid is smashing my kids
you know over the head so he goes to
give me fist bump and i just [ __ ]
look at him he's like come on bro i look
at him come on bro
and he and then he just crawls out
so now this guy's [ __ ] getting
giving me [ __ ] he goes he goes don't
even [ __ ] act like you weren't mean
mugging my kid and i go your kid smashed
the ball over my kid's head twice and
before he even said he goes no he didn't
no it didn't i'm like you're one of
those guys you're one of those [ __ ]
guys right
so um
i don't know we just do this dumb [ __ ]
it was so dumb it was so dumb and it was
so long and neither one of us was gonna
fight it was so [ __ ] stupid
and then
he finally has to go so then he's gotta
crawl out
right
he probably said something else i don't
remember so then now i'm out of the
thing later on
because i thought he left and all of a
sudden i'm sitting down
trying to watch my kid in all the blind
spots of this structure and he comes
walking by
and he goes all right he goes have a
nice day grandpa right call me an old
dad
so i go all right buddy keep eating that
cake
and it actually hurt his feelings he
stopped so then i stood up because you
know i thought i thought he was gonna
sucker me or something right
and he just goes i can run rings around
you bro
i can run rings around you and then you
just [ __ ] walked out and i was just
like
and then people the front decks were
like what happened what was that i'll
tell you what that was it's your [ __ ]
lunatic structure here where you have
kids of all ages
jesus christ you got like nine year olds
in there like jumping down the slide
where you got toddlers down the bottom
of it that's what's going on here
so um
i don't know
looking back
honestly on it by the time he saw what
was going on i was yelling at his kid so
i understand
why he did that so what i should have
said will say listen i'm sorry i raised
my voice your kid
it was that your kid was hitting my son
with the ball he probably he probably no
he wasn't you know i'm just saying if
i'm actually giving this guy the benefit
of the doubt so i don't carry this for
another week
that like if i had said that
um
that maybe he would have heard what
happened earlier and we could have just
[ __ ]
been friends
you know but whatever
i never said anything [ __ ] up about
his kid
i never took it any further than that he
brought up weight first
and then he he attacked me with ageism
um he was really annoying me he was
saying keep playing he goes you know you
got to be careful there's no you know
there's no bubble machine in here he was
doing that he was doing that that
classic [ __ ]
you know this is larry liberal and he's
sitting here with his meatless sandwich
and he can't [ __ ] deal with me and
all my [ __ ] red meat my testosterone
um
and i just love how he he equated his
obesity with strength what are you a
buck 80 yeah it's called being in shape
you fat [ __ ]
will you sit around and eating [ __ ]
burgers and fries all goddamn night and
all of a sudden now you're what you now
you're a [ __ ] heavyweight champion
oh my god it was the worst i was
literally went there to spend time with
my kids and like this is what happens
and i got i'm going to take my i'll take
51 of it
because i feel like if i didn't have a
temper i probably would have had a nicer
tone
but i was honestly
scared for my kid
i i you know what i'm gonna [ __ ] i
see [ __ ] kids hitting my kid over the
head with the i had a normal reaction
whatever but it didn't escalate and i
apologize
to the uh tonight's guy yeti for not
giving him the fist but i did leave him
hanging i actually went to thank him to
apologize to him later and i almost
walked up to the wrong asian guy thank
god he had the [ __ ] sleeve tattoo
um
he that guy had a sleeve tattoo so i
realized it wasn't him at the last
second i was like oh jesus i almost
compounded this um
so what i'm saying is i'm going to stick
to the park i'm not going to go to
anywhere
[Music]
i'm not going to [ __ ]
i'm not going to uh i'm not going to any
one of these organized
[ __ ] things anymore
i'm not doing it i just you know you go
to the playground they have the smaller
place
for the little kids and then they have
the bigger place for the bigger kids so
this thing was just like
you know
it was it was it wasn't set up right it
was inevitable
okay bill what are you blaming the
business now all right i have a temper
that guy we're both a couple of [ __ ]
met at a [ __ ] structure there's
nothing wrong with the business there we
go it took 15 minutes we got to the
truth of it
not one of my uh prouder moments
what are you a buck 80
what are you a [ __ ] fight manager
trying to figure out what weight class
to put me in
um
i did love though being infuriated and
still having to walk hunch back to
confront somebody it was really funny
um it actually felt like a scene in the
movie that i'm i literally lived a scene
from this movie that we're uh
we're gonna put up which by the way
we went to uh you know for some [ __ ]
up reason
any of those people listening i
apologize all right i take my [ __ ] 51
of that and i don't want to ruin
anybody's day and the guy i said a cake
eater you weren't that fat all right
you're like six weeks away all right
what are you gonna do i can give you
some tips
oh
um
anyway
i uh
went to new york
last week
out of nowhere uh miramax wanted to have
a screening in new york
of all places and uh so i had to jump on
a red-eye flight we went out there and
um
and we we screened the movie in front of
200 real people
which was exciting
you know because you're living in a
bubble where it's just everybody who
makes movies is watching it we're trying
to guess what people are going to think
and at the end of the day we got to hear
what the [ __ ] people that buy tickets
are going to think so we went out there
and uh it was really cool we actually
had it at a theater on the upper west
side that i went and saw pulp fiction at
in 1994 that's how old i am
when it came out
um i was seeing it for the second time
because i was still living in boston
about ready to move to new york i saw it
in boston and i went and i saw it again
like every tarantino movie
like i'm just going to go to it once i
can't there's too much gold in it i got
to keep going right so i went back and i
saw it again and uh and all these years
later i was there it was so it was
really [ __ ] wild
to be in there because i was kind of
thinking like wow because for the first
time i was like this is actually a movie
you know you're so close to it after a
while it just feels like this
you feel like you're redoing a house or
something um
but fortunately um it did [ __ ] great
and uh people came out they were very
complimentary they really liked
everything
and um
it was uh it was a pretty
it was an amazing night so i'm really
excited we're getting close
we're gonna fix like five or six things
rewrite something else do a quick little
reshoot on one thing and i think this
thing will be ready to be colorized
put some music on it and then you guys
can come see it i'm gonna tell you man
i'm gonna call in a favor when that
thing comes out
uh oh billy freckles is gonna need you
guys to show up
even that guy from the bouncy house
place
be funny if he goes to see the movie
he's like that guy looks like that
[ __ ] [ __ ] for that thing who
yelled at my kid
um
oh and then i get cancelled how can you
say this is a good movie then he goes
bubble machine
um
which by the way i think
children of
liberals and conservatives at the end of
the day i think the children still like
bubbles
i think every kid likes bubbles
um
anyway i uh
what else did i want to talk about
um oh by the way dude august 8th
do you realize what that means we are
like less than a month away
from the first college football
game and we are a month away from the
first nfl
that thursday night game that pits the
super bowl champion right against
somebody else who won last year your los
angeles rams
um are going to be coming out looking to
get their first victory i cannot [ __ ]
wait i'm still hanging in there with my
red sox
um
it's getting tough man they got rid of
jackie bradley jr i [ __ ] love that
guy christian vasquez i loved him poor
guys in the
the dugout playing the astros it's like
yeah buddy you're you're on you're in
the wrong dugout now you got to go
across the way
and uh
i don't know i always wanted to talk to
somebody like what's it like
what's that gotta be like man that is
just [ __ ]
nuts
to get like not only like
are you not on the team again you
immediately have to compete against them
and all these guys you love and you love
playing with all of a sudden are now the
[ __ ] opponent
it's got to be uh
g bill you're really going out on a limb
there it's got to be what bill it's got
to be tough
is that what it is
um
i'm not tough i'm only a buck 80.
i need to go to [ __ ] in and out
burger a couple more times you know so i
can get some respect down at the
playground
um
guy was trying to [ __ ] out dad bod me
i want to be like dude i'll take my
shirt off i'm just a big a mess as you
are
[Music]
you want to take our shirts off and try
to see who quit first huh
[Laughter]
um oh my god did i think i was past
those things in my life i'm 54 and that
just [ __ ] happened jesus [ __ ]
christ um
i did like the grandpa line this is a
comedian i i [ __ ] i i was laughing
about that on the way home was [ __ ]
hilarious
all right see you later grandpa
i mean come on that's [ __ ] hilarious
um
you know bro we good we good bro
what
and wait they should have a [ __ ] ufc
for dads who aren't gonna fight like is
the pre-fight like that's like the
comedy before like the beat downs
there's two guys who aren't going to
fight and they're acting like they're
going to but they both know they both
have too much to lose and they don't
want to do it in front of their kids
um
all right yeah so anyway i'm getting
ready to go back east i got a gig
wednesday night
it's going to be me and keith robinson
out there in queens
out uh out there where they play the u.s
open uh
not the arthur ashe stadium like i
thought it was it's the other one where
they used to do music i think before
they played tennis or something i guess
jimi hendrix performed there and i want
to say
john mcenroe jimmy connors and all of
them before they built that newer one
the arthur ashe one i'll have to look
that up but i'm going to be performing
there and i cannot even begin to tell
you how [ __ ] excited
i am for that gig um
i you know and then i am
doing a bunch of spots
in new york or whatever getting ready
for the uh the fenway gig
uh i got another one in upstate new york
and then i go to toronto for two shows
then buffalo pennsylvania and i want to
say
did i go to maryland i don't know where
i go but uh
i'm getting ready for all of that [ __ ]
all right so i don't have time
to get my ass kicked at the [ __ ]
kitty playland
um
did i mention the entire time we were
talking [ __ ] like you know we were in
some action movie we we were ankle deep
in those colorful plastic balls i'm not
even lying
[Music]
if there was actually an incident the
cops would have to go in there and look
at all those flat balls from the two of
us fat [ __ ] rolling around on the floor
with each other
um
oh my god
you can't do it though you just can't
[ __ ] do there's been some tragic [ __ ]
though there was there was one a long
time ago two two dads got into a fight
at a [ __ ] in the bleachers at a uh
at a hockey game
and one of the dads fell backwards and
hit his head and he [ __ ] died i mean
it's just
there's just no upside there's no upside
so i'm glad
that it just ended up being funny
insults and i actually i guess i think
he got the better of me
i don't think uh keep eating keep eating
that cake eh you know weight thing
it did make him stop though
it did make him stop but i i got to give
i got to say okay grandpa i think that's
i think that was the line of the fight
um
the argument
the discontent
um
there should be a youtube page about all
about
those types of things two people
pretending they're gonna fight and then
they don't
you know but neither one wants to back
down they just want to get the last word
in
um
has anybody seen that [ __ ] youtube
clip or whatever tick tock whatever the
[ __ ] you watch it on
with that woman is
for whatever reason lighting a car on
fire
i'm imagining it's a jilted lover
situation
uh
so she pours like an entire thing like
you'd fill a lawn mower up with that
alarm or probably a dirt bike i don't
know what she got like a [ __ ] look at
i got at least a gallon of gas
and she pours it into the back seat
[Music]
probably right down where your feet are
had a nice puddle of it
and i'm gonna say she didn't have a good
science background because she takes the
match
she lights it and then
goes into the car
like with her head she's standing
outside of it she sticks her head like
reverse ace ventura she goes into the
car
and drops the match and just the whole
place goes
and just blows it back like a [ __ ]
rambo movie
and then she [ __ ] crawls away
like a dog or something and then comes
running back because she's got to go get
the evidence and everything and i was
just [ __ ] cracking up thinking about
like obviously this video of it
the dude whose car it is is gonna know
his ex-girlfriend and then they're gonna
go over there and ask her if she did it
you know because she had like the hoodie
up and all of that type of stuff but the
thing she [ __ ] up with is she probably
burned her eyebrows off
so
then she's got to just act like she's
one of those chicks that shaved her
eyebrows off so she could paint some
real ones on that's the move
and then you just say nah man i was home
i don't know what you're talking about
you know and then you're sneezing the
whole time because you don't have any
[ __ ] hair in your nose anymore to
block all apart particles all the
[ __ ] particles dude
you know i think i'm gonna do for fenway
other than my act i think i'm just gonna
tell every [ __ ] up boston story i can
remember
and just and if it goes well i'll tell
another one if it doesn't i go back to
my act and if that gets going you know
then i just go back and i'm just gonna
tell all [ __ ]
meathead [ __ ] boston stories from the
70s 80s and 90s that's my game plan
that's my game plan
and i am sticking with it
trying to think of oh i've been watching
more of that that show uh the bear
on uh on hulu
uh about the restaurant man i [ __ ]
love that show incredible acting and
just the way it's shot and all of that
type of stuff
like um
i just can't imagine everybody that
works on that thing like the day they
rap on that season and they don't have
to [ __ ] do 9 000 setups in that
little kitchen
you know they do such a great job of
capturing
the lunacy
of the kitchen
when um
when it's busy
i was in that world for a minute
a long time ago
i was like 19 years old i worked in this
restaurant down in [ __ ] north
carolina
i've told you guys this story before
haven't i
i started off i was the bus boy
all right and my job was i had to
i had to mop up the floor and the
[ __ ] oyster bar
right it was black and white tiles like
the old [ __ ] improvs
and uh it'd always be [ __ ] dirty as
hell and i remember i used to [ __ ]
make that
oh jesus i sound like tommy
getting [ __ ] in good fellas oh he'd make
those shoes shine i used to make that
[ __ ] short that [ __ ] floor shine
and then i went in the [ __ ] you know
the men's room the men's room was always
[ __ ] up but then the ladies room was
just
it was just
otherworldly
it was there was so much [ __ ] toilet
paper it was like somebody won a
championship in there and then bled on
some of it
i mean you literally had to go in there
in a [ __ ]
hazmat suit
and oh my god it was nuts but i do
remember one time i went in there
and my manager was already in the
bathroom and he was brushing his teeth
while puking
he would brush his teeth and then we go
blah and he had the water running
and i was like what the [ __ ] and i just
was mopping up the floor acting like
nothing was happening and he would brush
his teeth for a few minutes and then
puke some more
and then i had to clean the [ __ ] sink
afterwards oh this was this was a low
period
in my life and i remember after he was
done puking he brushed his teeth he just
looked at me he goes oh yeah you know
sometimes i you know brushing my teeth
makes me gag
it's like dude you weren't gagging you
puking
and why don't you not jam the toothbrush
down the back of your throat your
[ __ ] size queen what the [ __ ] are you
doing right and then i realized it took
me like i didn't even think about that
you ever just like not think about
something for 10 years you just believe
what the person said i literally
believed it i believed that there was a
guy out there that brushing his teeth
made him gag he hit the gag reflex by
brushing his teeth which makes no sense
which would cause him to puke into a
sink and you'd think if you do if that's
what happens when you [ __ ] brushed
your teeth you wouldn't do it at work
you do it at home it took me like 10
years later i look back on that and i
finally was like
no he was [ __ ] he went out drinking
the night before probably till four in
the morning and then he showed up here
for the lunch thing still hungover and
he was [ __ ] puking that's what
happened
so [ __ ] for forever i was just
thinking like
well i guess if you know when you go up
top and you're kind of brushing on the
inside of your uppers
you know if you kind of lost control of
whatever hand you brushed to you i guess
you could maybe jam it back there and
hit the gag reflex
um
yeah that place was [ __ ]
that place was [ __ ] wild
and i remember uh
it was slowly going out of business like
most restaurants and what what what
happened was it first i was the busboy
then i was the bus boy and the
dishwasher when the dishwasher quit
they just knew i was dumb and not good
with money they were like hey bill do
you want to be the dishwasher too
we'll give you an extra 50 cents an hour
and i was like oh boy 50 cents an hour
times 20 hours oh that's that's ten
dollars
i could buy the new ac dc cassette tape
and have 299 back
maybe i'll get a snickers bar
i wasn't realizing like they were paying
that kid like 375 an hour that was
minimum wage they should have doubled my
pay i'm doing two jobs
i just said okay
and then i was doing both those jobs
busting the tables and then [ __ ]
setting up the tables and washing the
dishes no oh [ __ ] problem there
then the grill guy quit
the mesquite grill guy this is like a
[ __ ] i love lucy sketch
then they put me up on the grill
gave me like another 75 cents or a
dollar an hour
like
i should have been making like i don't
know 10 bucks an hour this was like 35
years ago that was a lot of money back
then and at that point i think i was
making like 475 an hour to do three jobs
um and i'm finally here to speak my
truth about the power structure at that
restaurant
so then what would happen was
i'd have all the dishes ready to go i
had to mop all of the both the [ __ ]
bathrooms in the oyster bar
and then i had to go up i had to prep
all the [ __ ] grill [ __ ] and then i
had my busboy uniform underneath my
apron and then i wore a tall chef half
and i [ __ ] gr worked on this mesquite
grill behind glass like i had any
training whatsoever and as i was cooking
i was looking out onto the floor seeing
who was almost done with their meal and
as i saw somebody get up to leave i
would act like i was bending down to get
some ingredients i would take off the
hat lose the apron
hey toots lose the apron i would lose
the apron and then i would run out there
i would grab i would bust the table
bring all the dishes back
and then quickly set up that table why
while i had [ __ ] on the [ __ ] grill
um
and then people be like we need more
glasses
and and i like i never said like i never
spoke up for myself i mean well what the
[ __ ] do you want me to do i'm making
shrimp root shakes over here you [ __ ]
what you could do back then
so then i would run back and do that
[ __ ] i would always have a couple
burners not on i'd set stuff to the side
so one time i was in the middle we
finally did a great lunch we had
something special and the place was
[ __ ] packed
and uh you know i would get the orders
from the line behind me
and i'd have to look at the order to see
what they had to make on the line so i
could time out whatever i was grilling
well i was so [ __ ] busy i saw burger
and i threw this [ __ ] on
not paying attention you know i just
[ __ ] threw it on i remember this kid
jason he was a metallica fan had a
little [ __ ]
[ __ ] wispy mustache and he had his
[ __ ] heavy metal hair pushed up
underneath his chef boy rd hat
and i turn around and go burgers up and
he goes dude what are you doing i got
you know i got all this other [ __ ] i
gotta make and i
he goes put it on the side of the grill
so i just took the tongs grabbed the
plate and i stuck it on the side on the
side of the grill
on the burner that wasn't on but it was
still hot
so then i went out and i bust a few
tables and all that [ __ ] washed some
dishes and i came back
and then jason was like yo
he's like bill what's up with that
burger right so i [ __ ] without
thinking i just grabbed the tongs not
realizing the plate heated up
and i turned around i had it by the
tongue and i just handed it to him and
he had his hands out like he was going
to accept the eucharist right
[Music]
and i put it in his [ __ ] hands and he
just went
it [ __ ] you know he went down you
know
like out of the like the window and i
turned around the whole restaurant was
looking at me
and i swear to god i almost broke a
[ __ ] blood vessel trying not to laugh
in front of everybody because it wasn't
really hot it was hot enough that he
yelled but he was able to put it down it
was in his hands for like you know under
a second uh plus he has chef hands those
is the tips of the fingers he's all
right right
and um
i crouched down
and for five straight minutes was like
beat red just [ __ ] laughing my ass
office as i was trying to apologize to
him and i can hear him but they can't
hear him i just heard him back there as
he was running water i was like jesus
and none of the managers got mad because
i was doing three jobs for the price of
uh [ __ ] one and a quarter
because i was not good at math oh that's
that's that story is called oh billy
dum-dum
and that place eventually uh
when i went out of business but the [ __ ]
that went on at that [ __ ] place man
i know i've told these stories before
but what do you want from me they
[ __ ] i remember there was this guy
who's a raging alcoholic
and he had lost his license for drinking
and driving so many times they weren't
even gonna give him back to him and this
is the 80s so that that that was a lot
you had to do a lot
to get the death penalty on your [ __ ]
license
and he used to ride a [ __ ] he used to
drink all night and he would come in
blurry out he's one of these guys who
was like 34 but looked like he was 62.
he had like a [ __ ] uh one of those
gin blossoms
you know just a [ __ ] red nose and i
remember it was like the winter time and
in the south like it gets cold enough
back then where you'd have like you'd
get a frost
and he would drink it till four in the
morning and then just [ __ ] pass out
and he would wake up and take a shower
and then just ride to work with his hair
all wet and i remember his hair would be
like frosted on the sides from being wet
and um
i apologize if i told this story too
many times this is just for any new
listeners so
basically this guy's moped was his life
and it was the only way he could get
back to his trailer where he could drink
it was [ __ ] brutal it was like
you know
it was like
it was
it was like an episode of intervention
at the beginning of it before we knew to
intervene we just thought the guy was
hilarious that he loved the booze like
you know
like uh no one was an alcoholic back
then unless they said they were it was
weird
so um
he showed up to work and we all knew
what the [ __ ]
moped meant to him
so
as a joke we were [ __ ] with him he
was in i don't know folding napkins or
something doing the setups and and he
was only working the lunch that day so
it was a joke
me and the metallica kid and i think one
other guy we took his moped
and behind
the restaurant they had like this shed
like it was built into a hill and behind
it there was like a little road a little
street behind it was part of a mall
right so we wheeled the thing
out and around up the road and then we
put it on top of the shed so he couldn't
find it
and he went out there and his bike was
gone and he had a [ __ ] meltdown
he almost started crying and we were
trying to keep a straight face and then
we were just like oh man i'm so we're
just [ __ ] with you and he's like oh
man you guys are [ __ ] dicks man
[ __ ] my thoughts somebody took my back
he called it his bike right took my bike
right like he had a motorcycle
and we went out there and someone had
stole his moped
i swear to god i know that sounds like a
joke i swear to god it's true and they
somehow recovered it they found it and
somebody tried to paint it i remember it
was silver and they put all these black
[ __ ] on it looked terrible
and i remember like three days later we
were working the same shift and i saw
him coming in
on his moped with his frosted hair
and his [ __ ] gin blossom riding on i
felt so bad i felt really [ __ ] bad um
and those are the restaurant stories and
i'm going to keep all the drugs up but
everybody was doing drugs
except me i was just a drinker back then
before i had my eight years of heroin no
um
anyway so if you want to see a show that
kind of captures that [ __ ] total
dysfunction
of the uh beautiful mess that is a
[ __ ] restaurant check out that show
uh the bear
um
really really really enjoy that i gotta
learn the names of the people in it um
i mean obviously oliver platt i know his
name uh he's in it but like some of the
younger actors or young to me i'm an old
fellow here
who gets into arguments that won't
escalate to a fight at a [ __ ] bouncy
house
jesus christ
a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know and then like
an idiot i told my wife that story
and she goes i hope he you know
you know did you look around before you
went outside i said yeah i absolutely
looked around because that guy struck me
as like okay he didn't want to fight but
would he drive over me with the car
i think so
um
definitely be a suv with his fat ass oh
bill still taking shots um all right
let's uh let's let's do some reads here
for the week uh stamps.com everybody
stamp stamp
um
i love that song by the way the end song
and the price is right it always
reminded me of being on summer vacation
or when you would fake sick and you get
to stay home
i said i would do a fake sick and my
mother would always give me [ __ ] she
goes all right you did it you got the
day off and then she would go off to
work
and then i would act all like i was
upset that she wasn't acknowledging that
i was sick even though i wasn't
um and then she would go to work and
then i would [ __ ] i put on
i put on uh the [ __ ] price is right
well that didn't come on till like 11.
that was the best
uh faking sick watching the prices right
all right stamps.com everybody having to
drop what you're doing to make a run to
the post office is a major pain
especially when you got more important
things to do yeah like getting to an
argument with another dad at a bouncy
house stop so stop mailing and shipping
the hard way stamps.com is your 24 7
post office that you can access from
anywhere skip the headache with
stamps.com you've heard me talk about
stamps.com they've been sponsoring the
show for over nine years now and if you
haven't tried it what are you waiting
for man
i mean come on the opportunity's right
there stamps.com saves you time money
and stress for more than 20 years
20 years jesus they were ahead of the
game stamps.com has been indispensable
for over one million businesses
uh businesses this is whether you're in
office sending invoices an etsy shop
sending your products or a warehouse
shipping out orders
it makes mailing and shipping a breeze
write up your shorts there tickling your
ball back all you need is your regular
computer and printer no special supplies
or equipment plus stamps.com seamlessly
works with shopify
amazon etsy ebay and more would it be
great if apple would work seamlessly
with somebody
um don't mail and ship the hard way sign
up with stamps.com today sign up with
promo code burr b-u-r-r for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page top of the
page sorry and enter code bird b-u-r-r
all right there you go and with that
and with that we are in just like that
people just like that we are into the uh
the questions here for the week and uh
the great andrew themless
um
incredible producer musician person
uh says bill great emails all right here
we go woodstock99
dear bill i was at your semi-recent show
at woodstock in bethel new york that was
so much fun man
what an incredible crowd perfect weather
and right on the other side of the hill
was where woodstock happened and it's so
crazy you go there and you just look at
the hill the hill is famous
like it's recognizable i thought they'd
have to be a bunch of stinky hippies on
it for me to recognize it um i was at
your semi-recent show what's up about i
worked a 10-hour day as a mason in
syracuse and drove three plus hours it
sounds like this is going to be a
complaint
oh jesus
all right
so you work more than i do when you
drove three and a half hours to see me
where you're disappointed
three and a half hours after work by
myself to catch your [ __ ] jokes front
row exclamation point now make sure
that fact doesn't stroke your ego too
much i thought you were gonna [ __ ] on me
uh your bald head doesn't need to get
any bigger oh
[Applause]
first i get called grandpa
i am i look like an old charlie brown
um anyways
on stage you were asked where woodstock
night are you asked where woodstock 99
happened
um
and i wanted to shout it out
uh
being in the front row well you should
have
but what can i say what can i saw oh say
i'm an introvert
um you don't sound like an introvert in
your emails dude
you [ __ ] ramp it up here uh it took
place in rome new york at the former
griffis air force base about an hour
east of syracuse
why don't we give it up to bethel for
[ __ ] understanding that that they
weren't going to get lucky twice so i
just hopped on netflix and saw a banner
for a documentary about the festival
titled train wreck
woodstock 99 yeah that was uh
that was not good uh which i can assume
covers the [ __ ] show that the festival
was although the first was also a [ __ ]
show but more in the bathroom sense yeah
this was more like price gouging and
sexual assault
is what i remembered from that thing um
i'm glad i didn't go uh i haven't
watched it yet but thought you might be
interested given that random music facts
is one of your 5 000 interests a little
shade there i get it i have add sorry if
you've talked about this on the podcast
already my six and seven-year-old
partners in crime sons are keeping me on
my toes lately so i'm a little behind on
the episodes
take care and go [ __ ] yourself um
i don't think i'm going to watch that
because i remember the news reports
maybe like if if you didn't know what
happened it would be
i guess kind of interesting
or whatever but it just um
i don't know man just
human beings doing [ __ ] like that to
each other it's just you know everything
from the prowess gap price gouging to
[ __ ]
uh all of that other [ __ ] man it's just
terrible um cheap bill you really went
out on a limb that's a really uh
it's a uh it's a
[ __ ] really went against the grain
there
um all right vitamin c and intermittent
fasting oh god
oh god
i tried intermittent fasting it didn't
work for me after six days i quit
um vitamin c i was all about then
somebody says you know the dosages they
give over here are way too high and it
could [ __ ] up your kidneys
so now this person i you know what i
think they're gonna do because that
person who told me wasn't a doctor
and now this person i'm assuming is not
a doctor and then they're gonna give me
exact opposite information and i'm not
gonna know what to do
uh dear bill the vitamin c article you
saw was about people abusing it it takes
a lot to hurt your organs or do
permanent damage with vitamin c that
kind of makes sense because wouldn't a
bunch of us have kidney problems
do i need to go into the kidney problem
chat room on reddit to get to the bottom
of this
i like when reddit gets to the bottom of
it with a bunch of people who weren't
even there discussing what happened
you know pulling pictures and splicing
them together and putting music
underneath it uh we're talking way more
than the recommended amount for days on
end
all right well there was a period there
when i was doing the movie i was taking
those emergencies and that was like a
thousand milligrams that could have been
good also intermittent fasting is good
for certain people in certain scenarios
i'm not a doctor thank you
thank you for saying that
i like this person
but how do i know this because i read
the full articles instead of just the
headlines oh you're giving me [ __ ]
glad you didn't though because i'd
rather you ignorant and funny than
reading properly thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself no i read an article about it
i didn't just read the headline you
[ __ ] i read a different article that
says the opposite of what you're saying
and then also how do you know that the
article you read wasn't from the people
that sell vitamin c paying these other
people to say that this is a good
[ __ ] thing to do
all right before you get on your high
horse
i noticed that when i was trying to buy
a [ __ ] shop vac
i looked up the top 10 shop vacs and boy
oh boy the first thing i clicked on had
the top 10 shop vacs and when you know
it everyone i clicked on was sold at
home depot
you'd almost think they weren't sold
anywhere else it was almost as if
somebody who was paid by [ __ ] home
depot put together a list hold up
of all the shop facts they have at home
depot
you know
so you're not a doctor either all right
so [ __ ]
i my misinformation is just as good as
your misinformation i will not be talked
down to as an uninformed person by
another uninformed person okay i can get
my ego just as much as you can
all right
i never made fun of his kid
i never went down greg i never went down
um
all right how to kill a lobster
deer billy basket case ugh that's not
even funny as much as it's painfully
accurate
uh first off love everything you do blah
blah blah listen if you're not going to
commit to the phony compliment i don't
need you to [ __ ] do that all right
i don't need you to get me excited and
then trail off
you know
don't [ __ ] put that [ __ ] on me
because you're not comfortable with
emotions
why can't you express love for another
man
um in your last episode you were
discussing
uh the most humane way to dispatch of a
lobster i was asking if there was a way
and then i read an article which i'm
sure wasn't the real one man
we need to talk to the vitamin c guy
uh my mother has a do you know the
[ __ ] fda is allegedly filled with a
bunch of people that used to work at big
pharmaceutical companies and they were
allowed to get those [ __ ] jobs and
then they allegedly pushed through drugs
that's something else i heard in a bar
um that'll make you uncomfortable and i
can't back it up with any facts
um about 20 minutes before dropping them
into their final body of water
wow dude
that was really eloquently written
about 20 minutes before dropping them
into their final body of water it's that
literally
on death row she soaks them in a
solution of booze and water
throw them in with the that bottle of
white wine and and
loose bud heavy from the fridge etc
that's been in your fridge fridge for
weeks
not only does it give them a last [ __ ]
there's a nice and loose
they're nice and loose going in so they
don't tense up
in the steam
and the final product is more tender
dude you want me to give like a date
rape drug to a [ __ ] lobster
you want me to drug my victim all the
best to you and your
yours from a fellow red-bearded german
irish [ __ ] from the northeast ah
god bless you
yeah um
yeah i just isn't it easier just not eat
lobster
it's just so medieval and we will bully
you to death
for you insulted the queen
we all know she's a [ __ ] um how to br
you just don't say it how to break up
with someone you live with
oh this is a good one
how to break up something with someone
you live with you know you know we
should know who know who should
jesus christ what the [ __ ] happened
there
too many hits to the head there um
the people who need this information
are all these morons you see on these
murder shows
um the amount of people that i watch on
these these these murder shows that my
wife thankfully has taken a break from
she goes through phases
where she's just like mainlining
dateline nbc
and um
we end up i don't know it's so [ __ ] up
because we're watching murder shows but
we end up getting a lot of laughs in
that i just [ __ ] tease her for like
what why are you watching this i just
start mocking how horrible they are
and then i just start singing go to
sleep go to sleep like why would you
watch this
right before you go to bed um but one of
the things i've noticed is the amount of
people
the first major crime they try to commit
is not only murder somebody but it's
somebody they know
that is the hardest [ __ ] thing in the
world
to get away with unless you work for the
government now um it's the hardest thing
to get away with because you're
automatically a suspect
you've never been busted for anything so
you're not like some hardened criminal
that knows how to [ __ ] handle
interrogation to be like am i being
charged with anything if i am i want a
lawyer if not i'm gonna leave
i'm pleading the fifth
um
they don't do that they go out
and
they they always bury them in like their
backyard there always seems to be like
like i got to tell you something right
now if your neighbor is putting in a
well he's thinking about killing his
wife
all right
if you're if if the guy's wife
says you know you catch her in the pet
store and she has a weird look on her
face and says uh yeah we got this we got
a rodent problem yeah she's trying to
kill her husband
all right the smart ones go to home
depot and they buy buy a plate uh you
know
a pane of glass that's what you do when
you bash it up
microscopically and you just start
putting it in their food i think that's
how it's done i don't know um
i know guys are supposed to be more evil
but at least if you get killed by a guy
it's over quickly like women i swear to
god jesus christ it takes him like eight
months to slowly kill you
you know there's a lot of women in
prison that could write a book called
the eight the eight month murder
um
[ __ ] hilarious
it almost takes some this oh this is an
80s joke it takes them almost the same
amount to have an orgasm as it does to
kill somebody thank you thank you
reaganomics everybody
um
anyway
this i actually believe
if you're a progressive school
um
there should be a they should have a
class a a requirement
that teaches people
young people how to break up with people
teaches people
how to know when a relationship isn't
working
you know
and then there would be less broken
hearts there'd be less murders
you know i would think the dateline nbc
lobby would do everything they could in
washington to stop these courses from
being treated i mean being taught
to kids in college
and you know what they would do they
would they would just all you got to do
is to kill it all you got to do is label
it as socialism or communism and it's
it's going to be [ __ ] this socialist
agenda then that'll be it
it'll be over
but um
yeah the amount of time
that you waste um and the people you're
hurt and all that type of stuff
so
you know there becomes that thing
i remember a long time ago
i knew this woman
and she was dating this guy and she was
living with them and she would always go
like yeah
can't leave now she just kept saying
that
and it did register me when i was
younger
and then they got a car together
and they they ended up breaking up
and the whole time she wanted out and
she just kept getting in deeper and
deeper and deeper it probably affected
her sleep
crushed that guy because he probably
thought he met the one and all that and
all you know all you need is just some
information like this all right because
there's a lot of people listening right
now
who want to get out of a relationship
all right i'm going to read what they
say and then i'll give you my my tricks
to the trade okay
uh because when you're you're you're
like a young guy right like you're first
like you know those guys that are just
like i'm just gonna act like a dick so
she breaks up with me
um stupid stupid rip the band-aid off
um put on bran a tuxedo you get a top
hat
right
you're learning al jolson song but you
change the lyrics and you just sing
about how you're gonna break up with her
i'm sorry i wish i knew an al jolson
song
um how to break up with someone you live
with here we go
uh hey billy red rocks uh i was almost
going to call it that special my that my
wife was like don't name it after you're
nuts and i was like you're right
uh loved your recent special and it's
also an uh you know more obvious joke
especially when my listeners are coming
up with it too i loved your recent
special and all that jazz thank you
let's get right to it
uh i have been with my girlfriend for
three years now
but have decided that it's time to end
things amicably
all right good for you
the only issue is that we live together
can you give can you give me and
listeners some advice on how to break up
with someone whom you live with thanks a
bunch
all right
um
this is definitely there's a degree of
difficulty here all right i'm standing
up now i'm walking around
all right
let's go with the positives
you're not with the person that you want
to be with and you're aware of it
and you're gonna do this
all right and there's no way to do this
without making a mess so let's try to
make the least amount of mess
okay so the number one thing is you're
gonna break up with her and you still
have to live with her now ideally
ideally
you already have another place to go
okay now there is a there are extreme
ways of doing you can do you can do it
this way okay i'm kind of doing the
cowardly way because you don't want to
[ __ ] deal with her
you you
you don't want to deal with her you want
to get the [ __ ] out let's just be a man
here you want to get the [ __ ] hell hath
no fury and you want to be away from the
fury so if there's a way that you can
somehow put a deposit down
on another apartment unless she's
totally dependent on you i don't know
what your financial situation is but i
know a guy
oh i know a guy
i know a guy this is how he did it
his wife went out on his wife his
girlfriend went out on the road
and he already planned to do it but he
knew that she was nuts
so he already had another place
she left and the second the wheels
left [ __ ] laguardia or wherever the
[ __ ] they were
his brother came over they packed up all
his [ __ ] they moved it to the new
[ __ ] place
and then they sat down
then when she came back he sat down
and she's like where's all your stuff
and he's like uh where i'm gonna be
living from now on because we're not
going out anymore now that's the fast
way to do it
um
listen you moved in
on some level you're gonna have to be
like
there's no way there's no easy way
around this
so
um
if you're not in that type of financial
position which most people aren't
uh
the biggest thing all you have to do is
break up with her
all right
you don't have to just stop
catastrophizing about how awful it's
going to be because it's going to suck
all right so what i would do
is
know that she's going to be upset she
has a right to be upset
and
just don't get in any arguments with her
and let her say everything she's going
to say
you know
if she trashes your family
she makes fun of your dick size or your
ability in bed and all the [ __ ] that
they
when a woman gets mad you know
god knows i mean it's all they can they
can
no subject is off limits
they will try to rip your [ __ ] soul
out
she might not be she might be cool i
have no idea but i'm just saying prepare
for worse here's the deal
every time when she comes at you and she
says that just think in your head
imagine if i married that
thank god i'm not marrying that
she is saying all this horrible [ __ ] to
me right now
because this is her last chance to do it
and then you're gonna get the [ __ ] out
of there
and it's gonna be good all right
and um
i don't know what your living situation
is
if it's a one bedroom
that's good because at least you can
sleep on the couch you won't have to
sleep next to her if it's a studio
i mean
i don't know this is what i would say if
she if she's making your life a living
[ __ ] hell
i would literally
call your parents and just say listen i
need two weeks to find a place
i gotta get out of here
and i would take a sick day and when
she's at work i would just i would just
take all of your [ __ ] your [ __ ]
okay anything even remotely questionable
hey i paid for half of that couch [ __ ]
it
leave it
just take all of your [ __ ] pack it up
and just get the [ __ ] out that's what i
would do
why prolong it
all right so i need more information if
people listeners have been in that
situation i fortunately was never in
that situation
um
so i can't
uh speak from experience but i do know
of guys where they were living there and
then the girlfriend immediately started
bringing other guys home
you know
have you ever been that guy
you know you come home you think you
know with the chick you think you're
hooking up and you realize you just
spiteful [ __ ] for the evening
the whole time you're like um is there a
lock on this door is that door
bulletproof like yeah i'm not
i'm not doing this
why don't you get all the way out of
your last relationship
i'm out guys like that's what you wish
you had the maturity to do
you know but as i've said in my other
specials your dick is a dreamer
your dick believes nah man we can do it
we can pull this off it's not gonna be a
problem he broke up with her he doesn't
care
you're gonna be fine
um all right that's the podcast for this
week um
oh jesus i can't [ __ ] believe that
[ __ ] happened to me what an idiot why
why didn't i just say we could i should
have said we're good man sorry about
that i i next time i i'm just saying
this out loud so i do that next time i
don't need to be that guy
um anyway that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll see you out in queens
and i'll check in on ya
on uh thursday